so uh first of all I love the movie
thank you it was just so great and it's
like I love you know comedies and it's
like not so often that we see him on the
big screen anymore yeah and I know
you're you've done some like TV and
streaming stuff as well but like what's
it like can you like I know there's been
a lot of talk about directing something
for streaming versus like doing like a
comedy for like the theater yeah it's uh
it's such a dream come true to be able
to make a comedy that will screen in
theaters because you know comedy is best
viewed with an audience it's infectious
when people start laughing in a theater
it's contagious and it catches on and
people people just it's we had um a test
screening for the film and it was just
so cool to see all those moments that we
built work and people laugh and and and
people even cry and get teary-eyed
towards the end um it's there's nothing
better it's kind of like test skirtings
I know because a lot of like comedies go
through like different cuts and they'll
like aim for like different ratings was
there ever like different like Cuts like
one because this is a very like this is
a good movie I can like watch with my
parents and like I was just like on the
phone with them like I can't wait to
like show them this oh that that makes
me so happy to hear
um this was like what is ending up in
theaters is pretty much the director's
cut we never did reshoots I mean this is
this is the the movie that was scripted
and and it's it's what ended up on
screen we did a lot of you know there
was a lot of fun that we had on the day
and improv that made it into the film
but um but this cut is is really it's
it's really like my first cut of the
film it's awesome yeah so the other
thing it's just like so amusing that
like Sebastian gets like De Niro that's
sad and it's always like a cool concept
like talking with even like co-workers
or friends like oh what celebrity would
I want to like play my parent and I know
you said this is like a love or to you
know your relationship with like your
mother yeah so I was curious like who
would you cast as like your mother if
you were such a good question
Patti LuPone okay you know yeah
he's got the
she's strong I think she could do
Sicilian I just thought if I was afraid
so I'm like almost like terrified of her
that's hilarious I can't wait to see
that it's it just yeah I need to check
that out so I know you're talking about
you know wanting to do like copies like
different genre because I know you're
more interested in working like the
comedy Realms so do you have like any
idea like of what you kind of want to do
like next right you're aiming to do I
mean I I I will always make heartfelt
comedies that's kind of what I love
um character-driven stories
um but I would love to you know and I
love experimenting with genres so I my
last film before this was a dance movie
this is a sort of a family movie I would
love to do an action comedy like that
seems like it'd be a really fun next
challenge so
um and yeah so that's so that's what I'm
thinking so also with like Studios it's
like
how did you um how did you come in
contact with like Sebastian were you
like a fan beforehand or did he come to
you yeah so so I was finishing up work
it uh and we were in post on that when
my agent sent me the screenplay for the
script and it was a you know an open
directing assignment and I just
immediately was like I have to direct
this movie and and that had never
happened in the four years that I've
been getting scripts sent to me that
I've leapt out of my chair and said this
is for me usually I read a script and
I'm like oh what's wrong with it how am
I gonna you know this one was just so
um it was as though it was like
perfect for me because my mother's
Sicilian and it's about Sebastian's
relationship with his Sicilian father so
I just immediately felt such a personal
connection to the materials and the
character and the world and
um felt like I had to direct it and I
had knew of Sebastian beforehand I'm
Italian-American I mean like my family
is obsessed with him
um and so uh but in reading it I I was
just you know I fell more in love with
him because it's such a kind comedy and
and those are so rare these days it's
not raunchy it's really it's kind of a
throwback to like those films of the 90s
that that I grew up with that that made
me want to do this so um so yeah and and
working with him you know made me love
him even more thank you so much like I
love this movie and I just can't wait to
like show this to like my parents thank
you so much well I can't wait for it
either